[Musik]
gibt es das glück im sonderverkauf bin
ich was ich kaufe oder kaufe ich was ich
bin
[Musik]
ist das leben nur eine customer journey
und wenn ja wohin führt sie uns
[Musik]
sechs reflektionen über den wert und den
preis der großen schnäppchenjagd
[Musik]
der beste deal um jeden preis die
endlose suche nach dem günstigsten
angebot erkenntnisse aus der welt des
schnäppchenjäger raffael
[Musik]
konsum macht nicht glücklich findet
antikapitalistisch liebevoll bezug dass
das thema so übersetzt land in der
schönen welt von xenia tchoumitcheva wo
likes und followers als harte währungen
gelten
ich habe mehr als 15 millionen auf
fenster ganz und ich habe für fast sechs
millionen auf facebook hochkonjunktur
bei der post im analogen zentrum des
online handels und somit auf eine der
giftigsten schrott halten verbrennen
männer elektrogeräte um an die rohstoffe
zu gelangen
mit schweren folgen
[Musik]
jetzt fühlt
so
euro kommen
[Musik]
für die jugendlichen ist es so wenn du
kannst zum beispiel dann öffnet so coole
das gefühl vor zögerlichkeit die derben
profiliert sich die junge leute zu tag
mein name ist studieren derzeit habe
schon als junior software developer den
reseller und verkauf alles en suite und
runter aber ich mache das mit uhr mit
wasser mit kleider mit accessoires alles
mögliche also über wenig gesehen
marica traf etienne der probier mit
steinen
das absurdeste wohnen bis jetzt verkauft
kann ich mit gutem gewissen sagen dass
ochs ist der virtual hat mit etwas
gebracht bzw flasche war selber designt
hat die hat man für zwei franken ins
kino kam sie nach für 40 euro pro
flasche
ich habe schon immer ein flair für den
handel mit afrika durch auf den sie
braucht also wird auf der tetra und dann
irgendwann in 2011 bin ich zu haus nico
[Musik]
oktober von kanye wests vom thron hat
gestanden für 200 euro kaufe jetzt kann
sich jetzt der msv steht jetzt zwei bis
dato sie krank der masia
sobald mir so einiges für unter 2000
fand ich eigentlich ziemlich schnell weg
in das tor der virtual ich dass die
seine vorfreude mittlerweile ist auch
der erste schwarze wo diese kolonie vito
und der hat jetzt mit 280 im moment um
die anbieter events der virtual kurz
abfangen und ich hatte sie kurz für mich
speziell will apple sich der designer
vor dem schulhof unterschrieben jetzt
ziemlich viel fremden person
natalie rickli wird darauf
unterschrieben hätte jetzt wird so viel
wert und wenn ihr jetzt irgendeiner will
mit zattoo sich frank videoausgang
kaufhold spiel streit über das erlebnis
mitten designer zusammen teilt und sich
gar nicht mit bessere sims nickel
konstanz
3 zum beispiel die limitierte schuh aber
niemand hat und wann limitiert die stadt
wird also ziemlich türkisch oder du halt
irgendwas gebracht hatte und fuhr an
worden und ja jeder versucht
etwas besser als der andere und die
dämmung profiliert sich die junge leute
[Musik]
trist aussieht war stich wirklich müsse
das stück ich mich sehr auf der
internetseite nicht nur reagieren lytro
spaß kontinent und hierzu tag ist so
wenn du halt richtige instagram pages
holz 4
dr was im haifisch die nächste release
wo gerade im heim sind die kommentare
mitglied abgrund dazu irgendeinen star
hat ja mit ticket gradus wenn es
unbedingt kaufen und wird
erpresserischer als angebot kathpress
ufer in teilen statt
[Musik]
also im prinzip wie reseller
funktioniert ist aber jetzt auf weitere
marke vespa kollaborationen hat und der
hand jetzt eben schon einig um aus
irgendeinem grund die informationen
vorher über oder wie klug schnell und
kaufe mir schlussendlich die 220 franken
die junta nicht länger kontrolliere
alles versaut hatte schuhe natürlich
verarbeitet worden ist dann wirklich
größer übereinstimmend jetzt zum
beispiel an der ems vor nike und objekt
und der zeitliche dann gekauft worden
ist weil automatisch das genaue modell
dann natürlich größe in us- den zustand
der es heißt das stück das so ganz neues
wenn der andere kondition hat und dann
würde in der 87
dann habe ich natürlich den hauspreis
wie deine schuhe 220 franken gerechnet
und am schluss geben was der potenziell
die resale wert so würde sie das war
jetzt mit einem schuhe um die 2100
franken vor meist über den tisch kommt
auf dem graumarkt würde jetzt sagen
social media hauptsächlich bildet sind
diese gefühle drin und durch sind und
zum anderen ist nicht vermessen
[Musik]
allerdings dringen
das nicht mehr kann ist jedes sie
möglichst das get together vds nico
interessiert die lithologie dies nicht
so ist diese spende die das stück das
ich dass ich darüber dass servicekraft
hat für folge dieses zu sich zwei hunde
sie sind eigentlich taten sturz oder
sogar mit dem bus um begleitet wir
nehmen hier netto begleichen
wir lieben es oft wirtschaftswunder
[Musik]
wir sind ja
dann muss sie gerade weg ist das ist der
weg
ich erzähle
im hobbit zu sorgen stern bei der
statement damit setze also handschuhe
ganz zerstört finden
das hat natürlich darf das mag
verstörend strittige fragen aber so die
ganze nachhaltigkeits geschäft der ezb
dar denn es gibt trends zusammen was
auch pluto langsam frage ich wollte
eigentlich nur das individuum ist
schwierig da durch große verein will ich
jetzt machen wir im laufe aber dass man
sowohl kanzler von politik vor der
großen trends der feldstärke heute die
richtige
es ist zwar gut für mich das lied viel
geld fürs cover welches für mich selber
einkaufen aber verkaufen was ich jetzt
noch dauern weil der jordan vor travis
scott davis cup ist ein us
amerikanischer rapper und sehr limitiert
und römische retzer b2 musik bis 20 uhr
hanni travis scott und dementsprechend
imitiert sie und will keine schon die
40.000 finde ich jetzt kriselt
riesenspiel 100 bis 150 dollar gelebt da
drin
[Musik]
ob wir noch mehr
über ge capital
heute ist
im
die bafin
ihr manager peter
the players said today
wir sind vereint wortes angela sie war
damit aber im anderen sind auch die ist
aber froh dass sie sich nicht machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vielleicht muss noch ballett suite mit
schwenker hat
[Musik]
ich nutze so zeige einfach den moment
ist
die konsumgesellschaft ist abnormal höhe
fehlt uns die sache natürlich gebucht
das ziehen wir in der frage wo komm mit
mir nicht leid durch eine unterhose hat
ja alles also es muss alles hinter
freizeit und nicht nur das was mach ich
möchte einfach ich liebe gesellschaft
gliedert
ich möchte natürlich mein beitrag dazu
leistet dass sich bald verbessert aber
ich kann keine idee wie wir das und
andere
du hast nicht natürlich viel gedanken
[Musik]
kann man vor zwei jahren als limit
gesetzt und ich zeit an ich glaube kann
schon mehr wo mehr als 500 gramm
gekostet das habe ich einmal bronze und
matthias nickel aber sie zwei jahren zur
zeit leben
[Musik]
ich habe genug von lügen und ausbeutung
ich bin gegen das kapitalistische system
weil es ungerecht ist
ich bin ja nie allein ohne künstler aus
finnland
kapital ist merkte man karriere war
journalist mit dem morgen alle
divisionen solidarisieren
er ist am ball war
spiritualität solidarität und
freundschaft werden meiner meinung nach
vom kapitalismus mit der gier nach geld
ersetzt
es ist revision russ ist sondern große
euphorie da bräuchte ich einfach dass
sonders kurzen blick macht das menge
spiele ich auch beschuldigt das jetzt
eine konsumgesellschaft aber bis zur
bleibt aber größtenteils positiv fiel
bis 320 und belegschaft herrsche
abhängigen möchte schnappe mir dass ich
lustig eigentlich da bin ich per zufall
gestoßen eigentlich aufpreis pirat
punkte dass ich vor eineinhalb jahren
als sekretär sonnenbad aktion gibt im
hilton sohn ins prozent und dadurch
reserviert im herzen und bin ich mit
voll kollegen gegangen und es ist
tatsächlich so wicki gehen ins konzert
gehen davon bin ich mit 24 5 sie
überhaupt nicht damit heilen job mag das
ein fortschritt dass man jetzt maximum
wird umso wohler weil apple sich ja wir
verschenkt geld und das da bin ich mal
wieder sicherung der schnaps solche
frauen autopreise dann natürlich tage
sagt gebot für die kita und so weiter
und so fort
geht's noch nix kutsche zum beispiel die
zickige und so wir haben ex profi
renault eingeliefert der lokalen
extremes ob es kurz angebot gibt es pro
tag verbringen zwei stunden damit noch
43 so jede stunde burgdorf preisberatung
setup ist schon hat oder auf top preise
übersichtlich stärker recycelt nun ja
der wechsel jetzt strom gehandelt hat
ein bisschen trasse dass sie schon so
sehen sich und aufpreis bereits aktiv
bin von musiker der vor das sporttalent
flugzeug aus hintergrund ist dass ich
mir sicher leicht sachen auf einmal und
man erleichtert oder zuschnitt ist
andererseits auch dass wir für clique
dass wir zum teil recht verkauft werde
und dass man das netz darf so jene und
akzeptieren so sehr gute schnappi da
nicht nur an mich sehr impulsiv zu
schlagen und dass ich name ist er
bestimmt gefreut verbunden
im nachhinein wenn ich merke dass ich
gerne bruch dann mittag bestimmt
schuldgefühlen wieder grund wirklich
sehr gute auge wurzeln hat sie rechtlich
verpflichtet oder auch mit der stückzahl
limitiert
das muss man doch schnell so schlau und
eine große verleger setzen braucht oder
nicht
wenn es einen bruch und wasserkraft hat
der 50 top leute außer kraft und nicht
bloß immer zu meiner guten preis
verkauft das e bike ohne kraft an seine
box kumulation vor mehrere kurze kurz
operiert 20 gucci miteinander kombiniert
im onlineshop erreicht oft sind die
gurte nummerisch noch ein und
aufgestellt zum beispiel beim e bike ist
sie das letzte fünf ziffern eigentlich
der klaus gemacht hat da wären die
anderen
dann kommt vielleicht auf dem kurs kommt
sowieso im schlussviertel sind froh und
postbriefs fall richtig ist oder aber so
gut gefallen dass man viel realer
politik und das im online shop mit
fenster von epm werkzeugs kraft und kann
ich das sehr gut ausgebaut werden könnte
weil sie wichtige quatchi weiter und
kombiniert wird das zwanzigfache
kinospektakel genereller willicher von
migros mit clip in dem es findet hin zur
pflege und der geburtstag berechtigt
planten
dann ist ihr folgt eine kurze e control
da sind sie schon mal gries prozent und
der nun elffache wollte kurz vor schluss
schaffte und dann noch mal fünf prozent
eine große kauf noch in die migros und
nummer 2 fach wieso insgesamt 84 prozent
zu 800 m 4 980 der verein zurück und hat
sofort im wert von 63 stutz kraft und
effektiv 180 sturz ausgehen
also wenn dir die handlung sich da wenig
überlegt und auch so eine fc-coach
generic machen dann sind sagen selber
schuld und lädt dann irgendwann die
händler können und wissen also nicht nur
letzter um raab anderem muss das heißt
also negativ oder mit forschern so viel
schwieriger zu finden seminare ist das
kalkschies das ist einfach der ignoranz
von einer handlung des netzes verlangen
und so ist sicher viele möglichkeiten
anhand erster linie galt ein wert über
konfrontiert mit werbung und allen und
das werden sie auch gekauft und der
natürlichen wasser das man sich wer
profitiert dass man sich schon dass man
sich dass man mit bestimmten produkt es
ist clean titels kreis würde ich sagen
will wenn dein dass man hat dann gesagt
anderen seite das sind nur columbo
die konsumgesellschaft eine kritisch
gegenüber wobei ich nicht selber als
opfer oder unsere gesellschaft aussehen
ist möglich die familien zahlten
und natürlich war das nicht die ganze
zeit unter kontrolle gehabt dass für öko
freak werden fans von smart und was
möchte das hat den luxus einer hand wo
man dafür aber sicherlich einfluss
das muss nicht mit einem zügigen
betroffen sind und immer das neueres
bestellt ich persönlich bin völlig
verzichtet heißt wieder kaufe dies
greife die eines grafen weil es günstig
ist
uns blutet das finde ich nicht so gut
andererseits wenn das gottes und stadt
zwischen händler und dass der nobelpreis
unter wasser werden wo nicht möglich
gehalten hätte man schon vor gestört ist
vielmehr ist sicher sind nutzer aber so
dass in den nachteil
der meiste kritik banks war ich zwar
ließ sind so unglaube sie sagt dass ich
doch gar nicht so gut und er kraft
sachen neben der kann nicht braucht und
wiedergewählt kritikpunkt ist aber dass
mit der konsum werk gesellschaft stehe
ich auch so aber ich würde vorspiel
hatte das liegt wie so viel schnaps
gemacht dass sie die sache viel mehr
wertschätzen auf sehr positives spontan
kraft wenn wir denn da sei immer schon
vorplanen überlegt welche das buch die
welt die uns etwas kauft haben
als ich mir sehr wichtig wie andere
personen als ich mal fragen ob ich diese
sind mich jetzt da alles klar geht will
ich jetzt auch ein sportler das für voll
sondern einfach eine als bewusst geld
finanziellen bewusst manche leute meine
kollegen zum beispiel die hand
überrascht - napoli beschafft und sie
finden es auch die freaky aber mit dem
satz kolleginnen abschieben darf man sie
zehn jahre verteilt
aber es ist sicher einer der bis
nochmals
[Musik]
ich wünsche mir dass die handwerker
kutschiert wurde die fähre einfangen
reduziert habe dass ich tennis kennen
uns erst mal vielleicht kann ich den
text kennt dass ich auch viel zu
aufwändig 160 für die user
er weiß genau was pascual sie wisse dass
der wettbewerb gibt und ich finde
schlecht dass jeder mal zu sehen
[Musik]
insgesamt betrachtet würde sagen dass
ich auf jeden fall profitiert haben von
der jagd gemacht das wird sich auch so
eine weniger profitiert haben aber wenn
man etwas miteinander kann man sich dann
sehr großer mehrwert so schwer diese
entwicklung auch ganz anders sie wird
[Musik]
nix mehr noch nie herr peter moormann
astra discover podgorica kapitalisten
gelockt
warum fällt es uns allen so leicht uns
einen asteroiden vorzustellen der alles
leben auf der erde zerstört aber wir
können uns das ende des kapitalismus
nicht vorstellen
heraus detailhandels angestellten
gemacht leider gottes ist einfach der
größte elektrofachmarkt die schweiz
geschaffen und aus diesem tief vom im
land einen punkt das ist ja eh nix sie
war nie wie
mit merck co
wie
vergiftet blöd weil konsumieren wie was
das für eine krasse stelle war die nimmt
und wieder auf wenn es darum geht das
noch
ja ich würde mich an die capital ist
bezeichnet ich bin fest überzeugt dass
das system so wie marcel vaid antwort
[Musik]
neben filip adamski nordbayern.de großer
wege gemeinsamen ökonomie
erzeugerstaaten abgelehnten dynamisch
[Musik]
müsst ihr auch der wachsenden sozialen
und sexualpädagogik gesangspädagogin
theologiestudentin medienschaffender
musikschaffen punkte super grundsätzlich
sind wir eine wohngemeinschaft und nicht
die kommune ist natürlich ein buch mit
ganz viel wasser ziert wird hier
definitiv nicht was sie in der lage sind
wir wollen aber gemeinschaftlich und
meistens mit einem zusatz beschäftigt
beschäftige sondern ist es gemeinsame
akademie heißt die damen so etwas wie
jährige sie kommen zusammen für ein
konto die frau und von einem konto zu
einem ihrer ausgabe besteht diese sache
mit dem ganzen zu 44 gegeben
naja das rating und das brauchen den
ganzen morgen ist es baumgart lee und
ling
heute gibt es überhaupt keine regelungen
oder bestimmungen zur feier der märkte
und terminen achten
[Musik]
meine reaktion auf die gemeinsame
ökonomie ist es klingt sie wie die
familie freunden von meiner familie sehr
erstaunt dass es überhaupt so das
konzept geht a und b viel unverständnis
für für die idee an sich ist eigentlich
nicht anders aus große familie
ich glaube dass die struktur oder
aufregung so klappte orte sind in den
letzten 50 jahren etabliert ein
[Musik]
ja vielleicht sich diese garten schönen
spiel gern mainleus kernen alaba
[Musik]
gute zur stock meinte sommermonate krass
aber irgendwie ich doch erdachte großer
garten aber nicht so dass meine letzte
vorhand die langfristig
michael jackson schafft worte menschen
zu tante jetzt ist glück über den konsum
zu befriedigen
das ist ein vollständig funktionierte
und immer noch funktionieren konsumiert
macht glücklich aber das ist einfach
sehr sehr herzlich das ist so das glück
war so ein schöner moment
es geht los man sich das aber nicht das
glück schien aber das ist nicht das was
wenn wenn du dir gebohrt und aus teil
verbissen 5
er ist eigentlich fit
klein karben
also dem ak finanzamt link wieder trotz
kalorien wie es mit dem kontostand
ausgesetzt wie zu schlagen die habe ich
hier sitze
dieses plenum raum zwei bis drei wochen
noch der mitglied der g power um das man
sich geplant und abschätzig lang so
wenig wie im radsport damit steigt auch
sony will kann das auf das veto das ist
es so dass mehr bezahlt gesucht wo ich
bin wir immer nur mittelmaß ist so dass
man unabhängig und individuell glich
sache habe ich hoffe bloß ohne dass mir
das mühsame und mp4 und frankreich gibt
400 franken ist der betrag war mir ein
bedürfnis wie der glaube wichtig ist
jener zeit das bedürfnis nicht die
verhandler sondern probierte belegen ich
habe das bedürfnis befriedigen
nun meine frage was wenn genau und das
geht bis an die akquisition von einem
bruder der zande und ja ich würde mir
das einfach mitlaufen
zwei oder drei wochen vierte sturm oder
hauptstrom ruft und gemeinsam ökonomie
verwalten und gleichzeitig würden aber
eine enorme unabhängigkeit und freiheit
aber mit zum beispiel malaria dem ihn
die nachricht dass sparer also bezirk
die grünen aus der sie mästen
[Musik]
zwischen 32 franken
aber wir haben zwei drittel sieht franke
doch eigentlich rechte hand nahm und
boni verzichtet jetzt bin ich nach orten
champions neue genossenschafts projekt
2010 gebaut ein halbjahr transit und gar
baustelle support unterstützen und
kuchen abzuschneiden
[Musik]
es war nicht so dass ich mich sehr
wichtig im sinn von größeren muss
mitwachsen und michael liedtke für die
idee für mich persönlich sein traum sei
die zusammenhält einfacher größere
finanzielle hätten und eine möglichkeit
so das projekt überhaupt zu realisieren
aus weil man jetzt zum beispiel einer
normalen familie
das projekt wird
jetzt geht sie
[Musik]
das muss man aber auch das wichtigste
damit bei gut läuft trau termin ist
alarmiert das ist vereint straße gehen
[Musik]
organisation hat ist es so zusammen mit
einer großen baufirma einsteiger general
ungen haben und wirklich linie ominami
klassischer organisiert sie heiraten
legalisieren wie finanzierte das projekt
ein sie zweige mit du musst alle und
klassische abteile wo man ganz viel
großzügiger mensch
ich persönlich hätte mir dank dass das
das metas kantensteine finanziell
leichter wenn die zahlen aber schöne ist
dass man sagt der ok citigroup wieder
abholen und dann beruhigen und ja also
wieder die stiefel gemeinsam frühstücken
und mittag zwei stunden woche und einer
hannover
genau an die daube bootstaufe dienst
richtung
[Musik]
ja mit dem nachnamen lisa zurück
besprochen
vor der baustelle wird womit die usa
über die aus dem grund weil diese bank
arbeitszeit aus eigenkapital errechnet
um inter ist eine miese belegen und
dokumentieren
geleitet wird das projekt nicht
finanzierbar sind
ohne die möglichkeit
[Musik]
dank
die gemeinschaft probiert nachdem ihr
kommen
es besteht natürlich mit der sehr stark
die solidarischen komponenten was immer
wichtiger sind harmonie cello und
bringen uns titel oder jetzt als
unbegründet
wo muss ich auch nicht jeder monaco und
zahle das ist nur möglich durch das dass
sie so wie der gemeinschaft aufgefangen
werden
[Musik]
herbert werner das ist dieses dort ab wo
man vor zwei jahren gründete und hier
konnten wir cbd haben es nicht geschafft
der partie beinahe schon aktiv so
geschafft und hauptaktionärin vorher war
die segmente ökonomie dementsprechend
und das war hier wirtschaft also dass
boni aus lohn bekommen wieder zurück
gemeinsam ihr können
kritisches nötig simple glaube dass ich
mich im bezirk zum gern geld ermöglichte
ein vieles und trinken drogen nahmen
auch so fair dass es wegen den ort und
wie es die wirtschaftlichkeit vermessung
steigt mich hat das nicht weg
philosophie jede das bringt da es nicht
mehr anleger genau so am markt wie sie
die konkurrenz um diese markt einnahmen
die probieren einfach mittel ab eine
sozia dass sie mir die herzenswünsche
erfolg wichtig sie und setzte die
energie und wann der ideen weniger einer
gu für irgendwelche konsum adecco und
wirte logo und motto film muss schaffen
zwischen ansteigen wenn wir das ungemein
führt das haus baut das politische
engagiert und zwei top häufigkeit
zunehmen
ich war schon mal noch schloss
es ist klar so google
[Musik]
ich glaube ich sehe bei der ganzen sache
mit dem alter ich habe ihnen eine
perspektive für die zukunft bauen das
vorstellen
die generationen zusammen und das soll
alles zusammen
[Musik]
warum sagen sie uns allen dass es
möglich ist ein raumschiff zu mieten um
zum mond zu fliegen aber unmöglich den
menschen ihre grundrechte zu geben
als der mensch in der höhle lebte war
die welt noch in ordnung er war jäger
und sammler
er brauchte nicht viele dinge etwas zum
anziehen einen speer zum jagen
heute besitzt ein europäer 10.000 dinge
wie konnte das passieren
der mensch ist immer noch jäger und
immer noch sammler aber es gibt viel
mehr zu jagen und viel mehr zu sammeln
der mensch sagt schnäppchenaktionen
rabatte gelegenheiten und dabei sammelt
er zeug zum kochen gab es früher einfach
feuer
heute gibt es dafür einen herd und den
backofen und die mikrowelle und die
kaffeemaschine und ins thema und dem
toaster und den grill und den
brotbackautomaten den thermomix und die
fritteuse aber man kann noch andere
tolle sachen für die kirche kaufen
den knoblauch schneider den bananen
schneider den wassermelonen schneider
die apfel shell maschine die zwiebel
brillen die bürger presse das spaghetti
maß und den kirschkern entferner
mit diesen dingen geht kaufen ganz
leicht wo viel gekocht wird wird viel
gegessen wenn man zuviel ist wird man
dick wenn man zu dick ist macht man eine
diät und auch da gibt es viele zum
beispiel fdh friss die hälfte oder
intervall fasten zwei tage in der woche
nichts essen oder die paläo diät nur
noch essen was es in der steinzeit gab
vielleicht funktionieren diese diäten
auch beim konsum hdh kauft die hälfte
intervall fasten zwei tage in der woche
nichts kaufen oder die parodiert nur
noch kaufen was es in der steinzeit gab
und dann fängt alles wieder von vorne an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war
[Musik]
sie versuchen uns alles als diät
produkte zu verkaufen
bier ohne alkohol kaffee ohne koffein
eiscreme ohne fett
es ist an der zeit die revolutionen zu
stoppen und eine richtige durchzuführen
[Musik]
die petrom welche die us presse ich bin
ein wenig kontrollfreak so für mich das
ist wichtig ich bin deswegen liebe ich
das internet weil ich kann ziemlich
sender entscheiden oh ja auch manchmal
you can't seem like me blick wie nie
die digitale verführung als ungemein
starke messe für wenn mir der druck
wachsen muss müsste das angenehme
zeitraum interessiert sie ausgesprochen
geringe gleiche musik ganz gezielt
einsetze um mit personalisierten werden
bitteren rückschlag
[Musik]
er wird radioaktives ki moon am
richtigen ort den hochschulen wie der
fachhochschule nordwestschweiz
[Musik]
habe mir heute von customer journey und
wird mir taktisch noise cancelling
kopfhörer-anschluss kunden reise begibt
phase 1 bewusstsein prediger und dem
flugzeug möglich frau theron entspanne
[Musik]
hallo ich bin gesegnet schumi ich
arbeite als einziger am facebook
sozialen netzwerke experten und
entfernten
ich habe ungefähr mehr als 15 millionen
auf günstige haben von vorne los und ich
habe fast sechs millionen auf facebook
habe content geht um mehr content geht
und nie gestoppt mit der viel konstanz
ich hatte glück dass einige große pages
auf facebook haben mein content verteilt
organisch jaja 100 prozent wenn wir
google suche starten
denn passiert relativ fünfte eine
plattform keywords monika war tricks für
werbeanzeigen dass google shopping mit
den grazer dem keyword passende produkt
zeigt wenn edf seine plattform mit trakt
das interesse da ist alles aus wie eine
kampagne laufen automatisiert die da
haben wir ganz produktkatalog von
onlineshops verknüpft mit der plattform
google facebook kann man ein gutes
marketing machen dass sie stellen wenn
im internet verfolgt wird ein produkt
imarketing erinnert den kunden dass er
sich für ein produkt interessiert hat
besuchte eine website erhält er ein
cookie dieses wird auf seinem gerät
gespeichert läuft er weiter sieht er
möglicherweise werbung von zum beispiel
kopfhörern
so wird das verhalten des konsumenten
online verfolgt
runde wissen womit sich die
informationen wo sie es geahnt sind
busch leiter und der kasse machen darauf
kein normaler wie es kam auch die
maßnahme spannender sind eigentlich
verhaltenen start der pos im onlineshop
also auf allen kategorien kukksi ist
welche produkte aufgelegt hat man
logisch dass nicht einzelne personen
sondern nur geduld gruppe von
kundenverhalten und probieren
kosteninformationen außerdem gezielt das
muss jetzt vieles was ich der nächste
werbemedium ist in florenz sie ins
erfahrene von customer journey aus dass
sie ist mit aggressiven spiel jede
sicherheit die neue produkt aufmerksam
machen und die kosten ja ich bin hier in
genf heute hauptsächlich mit meister
shandong die markenfilm ich immer
[Musik]
auch zu genießen damit auch zukunft
anzugehen als joghurt
[Musik]
also hallo meine leute gespräche sind im
deutschen kasten
wir sind hier mit den schwarzen versehen
die blumen stehen die sogar ohne sie den
filmen und ein mord party und es erklärt
instagram sie erzählen und 7 millionen
leute mich mit den blumen und sagte wir
profitieren verdienst warum bist du so
neugierig sicher das ist nur dass beruf
[Gelächter]
was lasst ihr euch das engagement ein
bisschen jakob ja das engagement von
xenia da möchte ich jetzt persönlich
nicht darüber sprechen dass musik
vielleicht sagen ich kann nicht so kann
ich nachvollziehen aber ich kann
vielleicht was dazu sagen wie wir
normalerweise bei moet hennessy mit
influenza umgehen und die werden bei uns
nicht bezahlt wir bieten ihnen an
zu events zu kommen wo eben nicht jeder
zugang hat und geben ihnen andere
goodies was er so in exklusivität geht
ich glaube viele leute verständigt dass
bei einem freund zu sein
es ist nicht nur produkte zu bewerben
ich würde sagen das ist vielleicht 30
prozent der rest ist die beziehung die
du hast mit deiner followers was dein
messages und das hat nichts zu tun nur
mit verkaufen sonst es würde zu drei
sein und will ist nie volleres härten
verbunden
[Musik]
die post muss zu machen für malt im
vertrag haben wir 22 für eine
zusammenarbeit vereinbart auf welchen
posten story desto besonders stolz
die von gestern hat mir gut gefallen
aber alles was die leute haben eine
reaktion zum positivität bin ich stolz
ich glaube es soziale netzwerke sind
auch wenn du hast 104 geben die diese
medien dokument weil du hast deine
schöne foto dew
august ist es und es gibt eine reaktion
sofort es ist weniger eine droge für
mich das ist
ich habe kein problem ich kann das
kontrollieren ich kann das verstehen
[Musik]
google zu den kosten
so bin ich jetzt gerade diese chance da
ich weiß dass große familie freunde ja
schon so brauche man im letzten anschlag
macht für menschen ohne schwere die
erfahrung dass 2016 erwartet gestiegen
wie und wo überall versucht 139 runde
auf allen plattformen und platt jährige
zu erreichen wo irgend wie möglich sind
wie letztlich muss die werbung etwa
vorsichtig und aufhalten und dass man
gemeint war das ist mobile device völlig
ein stoff instagram oder oder facebook
für lichte das display von hofer
newsplattform als 7000 mann der im ziel
das man am grund der krater und nicht
wie derzeit bestrafen fällt die der hund
immer am schluss und es gehört ein check
up prozess dazu musste der bestellung
abdrucken
also sei groß sagt ich bin natürlich
steht also stand durch die mechanismen
verstehen
jetzt ist sie hofften jetzt mal wieder
sonne tricks möglich instagram system
stier oder facebook und ebay befassen
mit einem produkt und vielleicht ob es
ein fluch auf über schneite doch
das waren die online shops mit dem
größten umsatz in der schweiz 2018
amazon.de mit 660 millionen zalando
punkt ch mit 785 millionen digitec
galaxis mit 950 millionen
wie wird prozent mehr umsatz machen eine
black rider so genaue zahlen gebe wären
eigentlich nicht raus was wir
grundsätzlich am black friday sagen
können ist dass es uns jedes jahr wieder
groß überrascht wie viele konsumenten
doch auf diese tage anspringen profis
doppelt soviel oder chris prozent mehr
wie ein normaler tag ist es geht es
deutlich über doppelt soviel hinaus
jedes unternehmen mit seinem
kommerzielle interesse versucht der
kunde zu erreichen der generale um in
diesem markt und auch wir versuchen mit
digitale lösungen auf personalisierte
arzt der kunde zu erreichen
retargeting glaube wir ist ein
sinnvolles mittel wenn der kunde etwas
angestellt hat noch kein kaufabschluss
gemacht hat ist es gut immer auf andere
wege noch mal wieder auf das angebot
zurück
auch werde das macht und der hund quasi
redet dass er das produkt durch solche
oder produkte denn für ihn ja schon wenn
man es verführen möchte stimmig dieses
statement vollständig zu ich würde es
positiver erwähne und ich würde sagen
wir nennen das marketing
heute bin ich beim wie sie lampen ein
sponsor weil ich hab schon lange wenig
gewesen und es ist mein erstes mal in
diese musik und ich war dann ein wenig
brillen anschauen für mich selbst weil
ich habe viele villen ich liebe prinz
achmed und ich will dass die leute das
auch verstehen zum beispiel wegen
botschafterin von den juden
[Musik]
sein wirtschaftsstudium sicher hielt
mich in ein teil von was ich mache weil
es gibt mehrere themen die haben mit
business es ist anwesend
autolog stone prozent von android sein
und ich bin super zufrieden
ich will so dass nicht eine ist das
posten also auf stories sichert 100
warum ist schön weil es sagt die
geschichte das war ich bin was ich mache
und die brillen also die sonnenbrille
gefallen ist so meinen stil brauchst du
also wahrscheinlich muss ein wenig
überlegen weil die sind ziemlich teuer
aber ich bin schon verliebt das war sehr
sehr gutes team aus ich habe auch spesen
mein leben nicht nur einfach shopping
und shopping den ganzen tag die zukunft
dieses markt kann wirklich unglaublich
science fiction werden weil es existiert
schon dass es gibt aber tagesverlauf die
sind die gedanken
also wird irgendwann avatar von kenia
geben dem markt kommt gute frage
ich weiß es nicht wahrscheinlich schon
[Musik]
mittel wieder sie hat schon acht für
einphasige die frau interessant ist dass
ein kurs und sonys ausländer machen
aufpasste rund 290 aufführen oldenburg
beim ball drüber grundkrankheit der
pause die titel master me you missed mir
zeigen sich sony entscheide
usb-anschluss besserer sound würde ich
sagen hätte sony also die worden ist das
möglichst konsument ich hoffe ich dass
sie das sehr klar im kopf wie viel ist
wenn ihr wenn man also bei mir klar wie
anfällig die an japan
es ist ein antrag nur zwei das produkt
das grund sie bei die neue maschine
aufgrund von brand mit prosecco die
technisch leichter werden wo es am
günstigsten fahren bevor
farbig von media markt offenbar weise
2.2 user hier wird relativ genau wie
viele kundenkontakte sinnvoll sind bis
zu einer stelle grund und weil
zusätzliche kontakte bringt und er
versucht hat komponiert stopp bei sky zu
ersatz stetiger mehr generieren
der kunde hat während des customer
journey es zwischen 10 und 20 kontakte
mit dem produkt sogenannte touchpoints
[Musik]
seit anfang aber wenn ich ganz ohne
fahrer am berlin unterschrieben probiert
die sonne zumindest tut irgendwie gut
geht aber doch enttäuscht sind dass das
geld das man konsumenten bewusst image
und wird zum schluss seinen motiven
gefragt und deine krone richtung aus
fußach sprachen für sony das schnelle
regelung steht aber jetzt auch
arbeitskollegen automatischer für die
marke boss endlich etwas großes risiko
wenn es denn endlich annehmen oder 12
auf ihr zu tag
[Musik]
frau künast dass sein mandant weise dann
greta sagen wir mal ich habe genug von
einer welt in der echte alternativen
nicht vorstellbar sind
ich habe genug von einer welt in der es
ausreicht cola dosen zu recyceln ein
paar euro für wohltätige zwecke an
hungernde kinder zu spenden nur damit
wir uns wohl fühlen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
morgen muss
rohstoffe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und gehört zur gesellschaft oder eine
sehr gut und konsumieren was mir aber da
haben das war zu verschiedenen anderen
das an sich bis kurz das gibt diesem
abend
[Musik]
der schlepperfahrer grabmal sie laden
san siro box oder gerade feldpark mit
rohstoff wort schreibende schoben ich
habe vor 40 oder gefangen und dadurch
jährlich vor allem wann blüht mich
inklusive rheinischen deswegen haben wir
einen tag die in ruhiger film nachgehen
schweiz priorisiert muss warten nimmt
deutlich hauptsache immer mehr zu und
sagen ich mache ich auch nie
schwierigkeiten aber alles noch einmal
so schwager entzückt wie auch immer
traum wäre gut sind lade und gut so
absolvierten oder der platz 40 fahrer
unter k unterhalb von den und kantoren
bringen
[Musik]
die koordinaten damit die weiße weste
wahren
tania cagnotto aus italien kranführerin
tatsächlich wieder zur stand ich zum vfb
stehe
bereits land blickt
damit die weiß das tor auf 4 kontakten
[Musik]
mit kranfahrer dass sie glaube clara wie
sika und für mehr leibe
konsum sport
das heißt dass sie arbeit haben
[Musik]
diese fragen
fotos hoch stroh ist zwar 20 container
vor nach b bringt
[Musik]
mit rahmen job
wie schon für heute ganztag musik los
und das ist sehr wichtig und ich
studiere selbstständig gern große
fahrzeug trotz fortzufahren nach einer
umfrage wurde vor
der heißt containern um 12 21 uhr
samstag 220 platz fahrzeug vater und
annina lüfter bringt containers co2
unter 21 monats wieder laufen und
darunter auf ein minimum
23 durch marco weißhaupt andererseits
aber
ursache ist bis kurz vor das hat was man
rauskommt
umsätze die sich jetzt zum beispiel die
weltweite bestand und nach werden
zurückgeschickt dann ist das alles
andere als nachhaltig und dann bin ich
ein großer fan
sieht gut aus mit modernen geschafft
werden verschwendet platz nicht
vermietet das ist so wie der
bürgermeister von einer verantworten und
das wird oder geschafft ich hoffe früher
oder später erschienen das auto nur ums
fahrzeug
[Musik]
xetra am 17
gegenpart zu anderen muss jeder in die
wasserversorgung aufsaugen nicht
verlassen
da ist keiner 5 0 sieg wir haben dank
[Musik]
wenn man selber zu machen sie vielleicht
nicht unbedingt ganz klar es ist nicht
lustig hoffentlich ganz wiederum stellen
dass ich sagen kann jedoch liebe 25 und
ganz wenige pixel weniger bestellt das
war nicht gut ich hatte mir weniger
[Musik]
die große die zweitgrößte die schiene
damit genauso sollte müsste herr alain
cohen machen sie so einfach super aus
ständig und die ganz schweren unglück
und zog ihn aus nicht schneidet in
europa und damit die frau wird zur denn
wenn das zusammendrücken diese ganz
bitter man jetzt über rechnung
johann nun und ich haben um es
steuerberaten.de lag stark hier und ein
trick darauf hat mich die füße setzen
und jetzt bei den menschen so bitz am
morgen mache ich damit der rektoren
standort und die chance war wurde durch
das ried vom sonntagabend sammelte ich
habe vorhin schweiz vom tessin und so
haben wir uns extrem vermutet dass das
[Musik]
die kränkung ja eben auch ein lob oder
man hält die seite ans mikro liebe zu
der kollision gebracht so der andere
macht seine sache
[Musik]
bei der wahl
mit melanie aus und wer der wahre
jahresthema kapitalisten kunst ist eine
lüge die wahrheit offenbart die wahrheit
ist dass wir über alternativen
nachdenken müssen welche soziale
organisation kann dem kapitalismus
ersetzen
[Musik]
wir sind darin machte mathias schläppi
ursprünglich komplett
[Musik]
es war
ich bin spezialist die sache
elektroschrott recycling und schweizer
regierung hat mich sondern diese
organisation miteinander partner
beauftragt in gerner regierung und
andere partner zu unterstützen im aufbau
einer nachhaltigen recycling system für
elektro sorgt
[Musik]
da sitzt der größte secondhand markt und
in dem sie hoffentlich auto ist sogar
fast alles
[Musik]
von holland in europa in deutschland in
holland haben seitdem so genannte
chinesische diaspora
das wird vor allem also jetzt nicht zum
die eliten der schlecht machen die in
der geschäftsbeziehung auf ghana und die
organisiert da sich der export noch 2010
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das thema der havelberger ich eigentlich
die größere handels oder handelsschiffe
vor westafrika
da wäre grund der innovations- gerät
geschickt und können daher theoretisch
das wo defekte schon immer funktioniert
der achtjährige klettere ich hoffe er
wird und basel konvention durch die
un-konvention wo der schweiz
unterschrieben aber viele andere länder
auf fast alle länder der auch das
eigentlich wenn einmal untersucht
gemacht das sind der betrieb seine
fertigkeit sind eigentlich noch
funktionstüchtig sevo exportiert oder
sind aber bitte wo wir doch eine
reparieren und den durch hus nach einer
kurzen und unterstrich die 15 prozent
und da ich habe immer noch relativ hoch
hoch großes volumen also dass er große
anzahl von elektroschrott oder
vollelektrisch hat das ist eigentlich
müsste es eigentlich illegal illegal ins
land holen so mussten wir sind jetzt da
in eine sogenannte range und
geschäftsmodell ist wirklich da das
probieren möglich die kreuzung barriere
völlig durch alte volvo nimmer
funktionstüchtig sind stahl user nehmen
und eine so dicke dezember baut das
normales leben über kümmert deswegen bin
ich nämlich auf league den ex aber immer
noch was heute metall drin wie kupfer
oder ist er den hat sie der
leiterplatten
der computerhandel metallen wie gold und
den probieren halte er die materialien
herz wo und gefangen natürlich dem
probleme
[Musik]
was immer jetzt für marco kloss
krebszentrum frankreich wo die ganze
kultur ali elektroschocker und mexiko
viele autoteile ich sehe mich mittags
eben irgendwo all die trainer sehen die
für ihre bleiben und dann wäre jetzt
halt dort verarbeitet und da wird halt
mit vorhand und da wäre nur getreide
aber ich muss läuft und ja das sind
natürlich bedingungen wo eigentlich noch
passieren und da ist ganz viel mit wurde
verletzt das selbe die sache ausland
nehmen rohmaterialien sucht findet und
das den wiederverkauften vermag die säge
treffen nicht reden und hören war
tausendpfund altdorf spezialisiert auf
dem motor und nimmt auseinander
zurückgewinnen
[Musik]
die gruppenspiele diese dollar wert und
den hot leiterplatte die b 28 und kabel
rund um eine unbeschränkte ganz wertvoll
so eine kathode strahl fernseher und den
jetzt bleiglas sondern und das glas ich
sagen ich mach das große problem zum
entriegeln
[Musik]
sammelquote in den ländlich fiel höher
aus wie geschickt sein das heißt sie hat
wirklich fast alles gesammelt für den
abfall und war zurück und es hat sehr
viel armut und das ist ganz typisch für
die länder aber findet man so wirklich
so andy eigentlich von der gesellschaft
für häufig auf der auf der abfallhalde
und hier probieren sich lebens machen
denselben abfalls ob ihre wertvolle
material arthrose nehmen die wieder
verkauft um so am schluss von takis und
wo sie sich könnte bis zu verkaufen
[Musik]
also ihr seid das ist zu sehen ganzen
apparat das ist der einzig teil was
sämtliche aufwendigen den abnehmer hat
wo der platz jetzt aufkauft und die ganz
recht wurde am boden liegt das goldtor
für einen dank seiner offenen großer
gerührt und was ihr im internet
präsentiert das schlechter und verstöße
projekt wenn die anderen das muss sein
dass die tendenziell entsorgungslösungen
für alle abfälle das nicht auf den trend
fielen oder am 10
die abgefangen haben mich mit dem
mussten angesetzt johannes christoph
loos nicht kommen
wir sind jetzt das mac welt und denke
irgendwer auf wegen der dampfwagen denkt
sind ja eigentlich keine mehr chancen
bleiben und mit den sich quasi zu
unterhalt der villa ganzen prozess um
einen minister bewusst sie das genauer
in euro statt ursache der ausblick ist
ein prozess und irgendwie die vision
dass auf dem marktplatz jahre
professionelle recycling axel
[Musik]
aluminiumteile wenn sie doch interessen
zu schmelzen
[Musik]
es ist ein produkt wo sinnvoll sind was
herstellen also das kann man sehr
positiv ich habe nicht einmal den
negativen wo man zählen sind ja wieder
sachen wirklich wirklich schön stolz
brüssel
ja und trainerinnen oder flussufer war
darüber steht und da ist die
katastrophen oder und dass wir uns gegen
wenig mehr user
[Musik]
bis 3000 angestellte zur problematisch
aber so war blöd wenn sie mich das
kupfer zurückgewinnen und den s kabel
findet die arbeits und plastik und immer
so kann ich nicht verkaufe ich das kabel
auch eine eigene und dem verbrennen zahl
das dass das kabel bis das ganz plastik
verbrennt tisch und hören dass aus
kupfer zinn oder der rauch ist es sehr
sehr schlecht
also da entstehen dioxine
wiedervereinigung bis von giftigste wo
man überhaupt kennt also das ist denn
die entstehende opfer breinig von größte
chemikalienhändler mit dem kopf zusammen
kannst du dir sicher was das schlimmste
vor
theoretisch ist das in ghana tatsächlich
verbaut damit dürfe nicht einfach so zu
verbrennen
aber aber dadurch setzte vollzug ist
schwierig also jetzt darum die polizei
trier fahren einfach große unruhe wenn
das sind mehrere dosen glüht oder das
fahrrad und das ist doch einigermaßen
heikel
vision ist das natürlich eine sexy
bestätigt zwar aber halt und für
nachhaltige hat dass er uwe barth und
rezitiert wird die menschen weiterhin
ihre sie kommentiere tägliche und
bestraft und und die lebensgrundlagen
das den aus sozial besser gold das
anschluss händler sozialhilfe gesundheit
hilfe z
das ist eine vision aber und führt er
probiert das projekt verschiedene handy
schafe und und die parks leisten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir gehen ist der vollzugsbehörde vom
umweltministerium und das ist ein
hauptpartner im projekt mit mit der
schweizer regierung und dem ende zu da
eigentlich sehr auf das steering
committee also des stücks ausschuss vom
projekt in ghana
außerdem schwierig zuschuss ist
ministerium selber oder wie
umweltministerium dennis ministerium für
feine entsteht wenn dir die zellen aber
der regel zwischen länder- und es ist
die schweizerische botschaft
[Musik]
außerdem rät sagen hilfsprogramm
besprechen wo man aufgestellt und für
die ganze vier jahre sowie zum technical
communication technology that we have to
choose between the country as wichtig
ist auch dass man apple blüht vor ort
wirklich zu experte macht vorliegen wenn
ich das projekt fertig und den solltet
ihr resultat nachhaltig da bliebe das
heißt wenn wir die expertise der aufbau
und das immer ganz zuversichtlich mit
wahnsinnig viel uetersen team und das
sind jetzt schon erkannt die experten im
land
sind die inputs machen wir noch etwas
machen vergessen und in dem sind viele
sind alle rechtsfrieden ausgegangen und
wir wissen aber ganz wichtig ist in
redmond widerfahren
wenn wir so projekt schafft und den auch
sie dort musik quasi alle anderen länder
überlegt man sich natürlich noch eine
selber auch wir dass man mit denen
konsumgüter um gehabt und haben den
black friday vielleicht sich überlegen
gewesen 100 franken billiger ist jetzt
wirklich auf unternehmensgewinne 100
franken gespart aber wenn man eigentlich
das keiner braucht eigentlich wenn wir
sagen immer das sind entwicklungsländer
also unterentwickelt die prinzip sagen
immer es mit dem mit meinem
unterentwickelt dem frage ich mich
manchmal über entwickler sind
also ich habe durch das gefühl mich
unter denen das lernen und tun nennen
wir unser projekt eigentlich auch es ist
ein austausch
es ist ein sogenannte knowledge exchange
das heißt mir wenn du auf das lernen und
sie einfach bis lerner und die mit 34
zum die ideale lösung habe ich nicht mal
ob es durch hohes metalle und zeigt
haye ist eigentlich wahnsinnig dass köln
war die rheinhauser allem macht warum
machen jetzt
[Musik]